I don't understand how the kids don't
want to be that being the favorite isn't
always easy Maddie so we totally feel
for you Abby might have turned you into
a seasoned dancer but she did nothing
for your self-esteem you had to compete
against your best friends and a little
sister and quickly realize that not
everyone was going to be happy for you
always being at the top can make people
jealous but you already knew that so
Maddie do you have any words of
encouragement for Lily catchman because
it looks like she's the new you contrary
to popular belief Brady isn't the new
Maddie
it looks like Liliana catchman is the
next in line for the throne and we've
got all the proof we need to crown her
as the queen of the ALDC watch until the
end to find out why Abby is so fixated
on Lily I just expect more of you
especially without Brady Abby Lee Miller
was raised by a dance teacher but
instead of pursuing dance she opened up
her very own studio when it comes to
finding Talent Abby has always looked
for the same type of girl and both
Maddie Ziegler and Lily catchman fit the
profile Abby wants someone who is
dedicated above all else small and
flexible and eager to be number one Lily
is living proof that good things come in
small packages
standing at 4 feet and 4 inches tall
it's easy to see that Lily is small for
her age funny enough maddie was just as
small when she was 11 years old when we
first started watching season 8 of Dance
Moms we were convinced that Brady Farrar
was the new Maddie
he was unapologetically gifted and the
obvious leader of the group Abby knew
that her dancers needed to step things
up and stop relying on Brady if they
wanted to win some titles so she sent
him home
but after a few more episodes we started
to realize that Lily was more like
Maddie than Brady would ever be in fact
we think that Brady is more like Kalani
much like Kalani Brady is older than the
rest of the group and is known for
having a beautiful technique getting a
perfect score of 300 is pretty much
unheard of we all know that Maddie has
won first place and been giving a
perfect score in the past and now lily
is matching her step by step it's rare
to see Abby's smiling and giving
compliments at the same time but in
season 8 episode 9 Abby congratulated
Lily on a job well done while giving the
other dancers constructive feedback this
reminded us of all the times Abby gave
Maddie praise in front of everyone else
only to tear down the rest of her
dancers each one of you are just another
number it's easy to see that Maddie and
Lily are two very different dancers but
they both share a special characteristic
that makes them stand out from the crowd
when it comes to these two dancers it
isn't about making a show or hitting it
hard instead it's all about emotion and
grace there's a reason why Abby assigns
dark and emotional solos to Lily and
it's because she always has what it
takes to execute them Abby gives Lily
the same kind of solos she used to give
Maddie and Lily knocks him out of the
park every single time but that wasn't
always the case at the beginning of
season eight Lily was making mistake
after mistake and she felt terrible
after one particularly bad performance
Lily tearfully told Abby
but Abby wasn't buying it she took her
out to a restaurant for some one-on-one
time and helped boost Lily's morale
Abby usually brings the entire group out
for lunch or no one at all it's very
rare that she only brings one student
out but she did this for Lily and she's
done it for Maddie in the past
clearly Abby sees something special in
Lily and she wants to nurture it when
you toast you have to look the person in
the eye but Abby needs to be careful
because she might be just repeating past
mistakes and that bears repeating
lily and Maddie might have a lot in
common but they have their differences
too Lily is much more flexible than
Maddie
whereas Maddie's musicality is far
greater than Lily's but even then it
looks like Abby is trying to get Lily to
fill Maddie's shoes she's pushing her to
become the next big thing we just hope
that Abby remembers that Maddie and Lily
are two very different people
Abby's former dancer Jojo see were
returned to the ALDC in season 8 episode
9 Lily was given the solo straight
escape which was a lot like JoJo's solo
straighten up from season 5 Lily
received a perfect score for her
performance but while she was supposed
to draw inspiration from JoJo's number
it would appear that she mimicked
Maddie's style Lily's facial expressions
were very similar to Maddie's in the
Lizzie Borden dance from season 6 you
can clearly see the similarities between
these two stars when you watch them
dancing side-by-side it's super obvious
that Abby Lee Miller sees something
special in Liliana catchman she's
constantly pushing her to do better and
giving her challenging solos that show
off her innate skill set some of the
other dancers are a little jealous and
it's starting to show Abby has an
affinity for Lily but she doesn't have
for the other dancers she believes Lily
to be a star and wants to help her reach
for them what do you guys think is Lily
the new Maddie or do we have it all
wrong
sound off in the comments
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Dance Moms and subscribe to the
thing so you never miss another video
thanks for watching we'll see you later
[Music]